[Music]
welcome so today we're here to talk to
you about dead easy kubernetes we're
close with Visual Studio code and to get
us started we're gonna tell you a little
bit about ourselves so hi everyone I'm
Sarah I'm a user experience researcher
on Google cloud platform and I do
research to understand and improve
developer experience with our tools so
it's my job to talk to all of you and
listen to your needs and pain points and
make sure we address those with our
tools and this is my dog smokey I love
very much hello everyone this is Sujit
I'm a software engineer on the cloud
core team I work on tools that improve
developer experience with kubernetes and
this is my cricket bat which is pretty
excited that after a long winter
somebody's coming so how many people in
the audience are developing kubernetes
applications or planning to in the
future awesome
that's a lot of you we're really excited
that you're here I've talked to a lot of
you about your experience with
kubernetes and one thing that I've heard
is that it can be frustrating and you've
said things like there's too much
configuration debugging is a pain
applications have so many moving parts
and you're just spending way too much
time outside of your code and so let's
break this down a little bit
why is kubernetes difficult well my
conversations with you I've heard a few
things like this getting started is hard
because it can be a big conceptual shift
and getting a HelloWorld application up
and running just takes way too much time
and once you have hello world ready go
the complexity of kubernetes really
kicks in because developers have to
learn a lot of new things like
containers yamo syntax and kubernetes
client tools like coop CTL and then when
you're ready to deploy there's a lot of
moving parts you have to build tag and
push your images to a repository and
manage your clusters and then if
something goes wrong which typically
happens troubleshooting can be a huge
pain because setting up debugging is
difficult and identifying the cause of
your problems is hard and so we want to
help you with each of these and so you
just here to tell us a little bit about
how thank you Sara
so let me now introduce cloud code cloud
code is a set of integrated tools from
Google that let you focus more on our
code worrying less about the tool change
configuration and management
Fedorov or the past several months we
have been working super hard to help
solve some of the pain points sarah has
described and we are very excited to
launch the cloud code extension for
Visual Studio code which is currently in
beta so what we have in this extension
this extension provides a simple getting
started experience for users new to
kubernetes helps with the local
application development streamlines the
deployment process and help you
troubleshoot your applications through
debugging and logs in today's talk we
are going to demo all of these and some
more so that's a lot to cover and we
should get started and I want to say
just as Sujit mentioned we're gonna be
covering the end-to-end developer
workflow with kubernetes so there's
gonna be a lot of code but also a lot of
really cool features that we're excited
to show you so let's jump over to Visual
Studio code how many Visual Studio code
users do we have in the audience today
awesome we're really excited that you're
all here and that we get to show you
cloud code so here I've got Visual
Studio code open and I've got cloud code
installed so I'm gonna get us started on
the welcome page was it's gonna have a
lot of good resources when you're just
starting with cloud code well you'll see
first off is that we've got support for
four languages go note Java and Python
you're gonna find information about the
prerequisites to have installed when
using cloud code and for context what I
have on this machine here is dr. desktop
with kubernetes enabled and scaffold and
like I said we really care about your
feedback and we want to make sure that
we're using creating tools to meet your
needs
so we've got sections over here in the
resources tab for you to file an issue
and request a feature we really hope you
use those because Sujit and I and the
rest of our team are constantly checking
what you'd like to see in cloud code so
we can make improvements and so now
let's get started with our first hello
world app as you can see here I could
get started right from the resources tab
or I can use the command palette command
shift P and I'm a search for cloud Cote
and what you'll see right off the bat is
a lot of contributions that we've made
we're not gonna have time to go through
all of these today but there's so much
for you to explore after our talk I'm
going to use the cloud code command for
new application and here you'll see the
support for those languages that I
mentioned and a couple of templates that
you can use to get started I'm going to
select the Python HelloWorld template
and it's going to ask me where I want to
save that and now it's going to populate
new HelloWorld template for me Sujit can
you tell me a little bit about what this
template has sure so all the
applications that are created is in the
cloud code new application command our
deploy ready and debug ready so in this
case we have a simple holo application
with a single micro service init all the
source code of the micro service can be
found in the source folder here along
with the docker file that containerize
is the micro service we also have all
the community resources of this
application in the kubernetes manifest
folder and we also have launched our
JSON file that contains the necessary
debug configuration of this application
and finally we have the scaffold ml file
here so cloud core leverages an open
source tool called scaffold that helps
us with building and deploying
kubernetes applications this scaffold
configuration file here contains one or
more deployment profiles that defines
how an application should be built and
deployed I would like to add one more
thing here that the templates we have
seen just before are coming from
external public repositories this helps
us scale the templates independent of
the extension and so time you can expect
to find lot more useful templates in
this area that's really awesome because
providing more templates for developers
is gonna help them expand their
kubernetes applications quickly and
easily so let's go ahead and deploy this
cuber Nights application I'm gonna go
back to the command palette and I'm
going to use the command the command for
deploy and then I'm gonna pick select
the default profile which came with my
template and then it's gonna ask me
where I want to deploy to and like I
said I already have docker for desktop
on this machine with kubernetes enabled
but we do also have support for many
cube so here we go we've kicked off our
deployment and we have it all ready to
go and there we go I just deployed my
first HelloWorld application and I
didn't have to write any code so let's
take a minute to summarize what we've
shown you so far we just showed you how
easy it is to get started with our
templates in cloud code and how quickly
you can deploy locally but let's really
get into it
Sujit and I have a question we'd really
like to ask you all the end of the talk
so we're gonna build a voting
application from scratch using cloud
code Sujit take it away let's build a
voting application from scratch using
the cloud code
extension the goal for the rest of the
talk is to build and iterate this
application locally and when it's ready
we
to a remote cluster so we all can access
this application the application itself
is very simple
it has just two micro services a front
end and a back end called voting service
even though we'll be using node.js for
both of these micro services everything
we are going to show in this demo is
language agnostic the front end has two
HTML pages an index page that lets us
post a vote and a results page where we
can see all the voting results and
similarly the voting service has two
HTTP end points they get endpoint that
returns all the words posted so far and
a post endpoint that will take some
saves in you vote so now we will go
ahead and show how this final
application is going to look like so we
all have a frame of reference of what we
are trying to be I'll go to cloud code
example.com and now we are seeing the
index page of the front end and we can
submit a vote and as you can see a post
request has been made to the /watch URL
which is being served by the voting
service and similarly when we navigate
to the results page we can see that a
get request has been made to the slash
vote URL which is being solved by the
voting service and it didn't solve the
words that were posted so far and these
words are being displayed in the outer
space here so real simple so now you go
back to the IDE and we'll close the
hello world application and I will open
a new directory called voting app which
is currently empty I will start by
adding or a source folder which is where
we'll keep the source code for all of
our microservices
I will get a terminal and I will use git
clone to fetch the source code for the
front end service and we will do the
same for the voting service the source
code for these microservices is real
simple so the front end service has an
extra J's file which is configured to
some static HTML content from public
directory and the public directory has
the HTML pages we saw before and
similarly the voting service has indexed
or J's file and it has the
implementation for the HTTP GET endpoint
and the implementation for the HTTP POST
endpoint
the words posted will be stored locally
on the machine using an NPM module and
both of these micro services have docker
files with them and now in order to
deploy this application to a kubernetes
cluster we need to have the
corresponding kubernetes resources I'll
switch back to the slides and these how
our kubernetes resources gonna look like
in our cluster for each of the micro
services will have a deployment and a
service resource that helps us with
deploying and exposing this micro
service within the cluster will also
have an ingress resource which helps us
in reader redirecting the external
traffic coming to the cluster to these
micro services so all the traffic coming
to the front are to the root URL will be
reader to the front-end service and all
the traffic coming to the slash would
our URL will be redirected to the voting
service so now let's add these five
kubernetes resources to our application
is there anything more dreadful than
writing camels on a beautiful sunny day
isn't it Sarah isn't selling us no not
at all Sujit how many of you in the
audience enjoy writing and editing ammo
files alright you got a couple of
friends but I'm gonna say the majority
do not so this is a great opportunity to
show how easy it is to write yamo using
cloud code because developers are always
saying that writing llamó can be
error-prone both syntactically and
semantically and we've got some really
cool resources for you that SOOC is
gonna show us let's do this
Arnaud git clone this time so we'll
start by creating a new folder called
kubernetes
manifest which is where we'll keep all
the kubernetes resources of this
application and let's go ahead and
create fronting Amal file to add the
deployment and the service resources for
the front-end the fastest way to add a
kubernetes resources is through our
snippets so I'll go ahead and press
control space here and we can see a list
of snippets available for us I'll go
ahead and use the kubernetes deployment
snippet and now we have a basic
deployment resource error let's change
the names
whoo thank you and I'll press the tab
and we'll change the image name to
front-end image and we'll do one more
tab and Leslie the content report as is
as you can see adding a kubernetes
resource through our snippets is
extremely easy and typically after
arrhenius new resource you may want to
understand certain properties on them
for example I may want to understand
what this particular resource does here
for that I can simply hover over those
properties and we can get a brief
description of what the properties along
with the link to the official kubernetes
documentation so next we'll add a
service resource will again use the
snippets will use the kubernetes service
snippet and let's change the name and
for a service to work with ingress the
type of the service has to be either
node port or load balancer so we'll use
node put here and press tab let's use
the port as 4001 and we'll leave the
target port as is because it has to
match with the container port here so so
far we have added both the deployment
and the service resources that are
needed for the front-end service so
typically after adding new resists new
resources you may want to fine-tune them
by adding or removing certain properties
so in order to add new properties you
can simply go to a specific location and
press control space and you will see a
list of I will possible suggestions
I will available at that particular
location so I can go ahead and use
external traffic policy here and press
control space again now we can see the
list of possible values for that
particular property we also have a brief
description of that property on the
right-hand side which will come in handy
when you want to decide which of these
properties would like to use but for
this demo we won't need this property so
will not have it so next we will try to
quickly add both the deployment and the
service resources for the voting service
you would create a new file called
outing dot ml and we leave the container
Cortese's and then we will add the
service resource
oops looks like there's a typo and as
you can see we also have a nice
validation support available as well
let's fix that and now we have added a
four out of the five kubernetes
resources that we need for this
application let's have the last one will
create the English store Tamil file to
add the English resource ingress
resource helps us read out the traffic
coming to the cluster to the services in
the application based on the hostname
URL path etc so in our application we
have two services the front-end service
and a voting service and let's rewrite
the traffic coming to the root URL to
the front-end service for that I'll go
to the service name and press control
space to get a list of available
suggestions for the service names some
of these suggestions are coming from the
kubernetes manifest in the application
directly as generated by the local
suffix and some of the other suggestions
like kubernetes and Python Halliwell
external are coming from the current
active cluster configured on my machine
so I'll go ahead and use the front end
service and now we need to know the
service port of the front end yes you
may have noticed the front end service
here is clickable so I can simply hold
on the front end service and use command
click or I can right click and use the
go to definition option and now it takes
us directly to the definition of the
kubernetes resource I will copy the port
number and we'll use it in the ingress
next let's try to read out the traffic
come into the slash boat URL to the
voting service for that we will add
another entry here you slash worth and
now I'll use control space once again
and use the voting service and now we
need we need to know the port of the
voting service for that we'll
right-click on the voting service and
use the peak definition option here and
now the definition of the voting service
is this is displayed right here in this
file these features come in real handy
especially when I have large number of
cognates resources in our application we
also have the same tooltip support
available in this mode what do we copy
the port number and close this and we'll
use it here and that's it we have added
all the copilot's resources that we need
for this application but before we move
on
I'll add a couple of annotations in
order to use a non-default English
controller and to stop SS every
direction ask you I just wanna take a
minute to say that you wrote a ton of
llamo and you made that look super easy
those resources like the snippets
autocompletes go to definitions are
gonna be super helpful for developers
who are new to kubernetes and those have
been using it for a long time so it's
really great to see those features and
so to summarize we've seen a lot of code
and what Sujit has done so far has
gotten the source code with for our
micro services and docker file and then
added all the kubernetes resources we
need to deploy this application so
what's next next we'll try to deploy
this application to the local cluster so
for that I will go to the command
palette and use cloud code deploy and
because there are no deployment profiles
created in this application so far it's
prompting us to create one so wait a
second CJ can you tell us a little bit
about what deployment profiles do for us
sure in real world an application
typically resides in multiple
environments such as dev test staging
prod etcetera and you may want to build
and deploy your application differently
based on the environment for example in
dev environment you may want to use
docker CLI to build your application and
use cube CTL to deploy the application
to a local fester such as mini cube or
docker for desktop and in staging
environment you may want to use a Google
cloud build to build your application
and use customize to deploy the
application to a remote GK cluster
deployment profiles help us do this for
each of the environment you would like
your application be supported in you
will just have to create a deployment
profile and let the cloud code take care
of the rest
so now we will go ahead and create our
first deployment profile to work against
the local environment and for that we
will click s here and now it has
analyzed the application and prompting
us to provide a mapping between the
image names in the kubernetes manifest
and the docker files in this application
so why do you need to provide this
mapping usually in order to deploy an
application we'll have to build all the
docker files in the application tag them
push them to a repository and then
update all our kubernetes manifest with
the image path the deploy process is
asking for this mapping so it can do all
of these tasks on our behalf so I'll go
ahead and use
frontend dockerfile for the front end
image and the voting service dockerfile
for the voting image and press save and
now we have our first deployment profile
created we can also see that the
corresponding scaffold our amel file has
been created in the application
directory so the default profile here is
configured to use docker engine API is
to build this application and this
behavior can be fine-tuned with the
properties available here and the
default profile is configured to use
cube CTL to deploy this application we
can add more profiles as we need using
the add new option here or we can use
the edit button here to add edit the
profile so we'll go ahead and edit it
instead of hard-coding
all the file paths I'll use a wild card
so we don't have to worry when new files
are added or existing files are removed
from this folder so now we will proceed
with the deployment and we'll select the
default profile we just created and
we'll use docker for this stuff for the
local environment and now the deployment
process has started and we can see the
status of the deployment in the status
bar here currently it's waiting for the
rollout of the front-end and now it's
waiting for the rollout of the voting
service so Sujit this seems to be taking
a little bit of time and I can see
there's some error logs in the output
window what's going on here looks like
there's an issue here so typically after
our triggering the deployment the cloud
code deploy command also streams the
logs that are streams the logs from the
corresponding parts directly to the
output window so which is what seems to
be happening here just a second yeah it
was not visible in the in that mode so
we also have a few other options
available to diagnose the deployment
issues and to access them we can simply
click on the status bar here and here we
can see the describe parse option if you
want to know more details about the
current pod status and we have the show
locks option here but because we already
have the error logs in the output window
I will go ahead and stop waiting for the
rollout let's see what's going on here
it looks like we are in index dodgiest
by line 13 we are using an await method
in an on a sink
let's go to the next row JS file and
looks like we are using a bit
incorrectly here in a non icing function
and because this bug is in the startup
code of the container the deployment has
failed so let's fix this and do a
deployment again now the deployment is
in progress again and now the deployment
has happened successfully so as you can
also see on the publicly exposed
endpoints in the application are
displayed directly in the output window
I'll go ahead and click on the front end
service here and now we can see the
front end of our application which is
deployed in the kubernetes cluster so
we'll submit a vote and see if we're
able to successfully post award oops
looks like the request to the voting
service has failed with an internal
server error there seems to be a bug in
the OT service code and let's try to
troubleshoot this issue by directly
debugging the application in the
kubernetes question in order to debug a
micro service using the cloud code
extension we need to do two things the
first thing is to ensure that the docker
file that we are using is debug ready so
in the case of node.js that means using
the inspect flag in the startup command
and we have similar instructions
available for other languages in our
documentation and the second thing we
need to do is to add the corresponding
debug configuration
currently there are no configurations
you can added configuration by using the
add of add configuration option there
and we can select the cloud code debug
here but I will add the debug
configuration a slightly different way
I'll go to the dot vs code folder and
add a new file called launched or JSON I
will go to the configurations section
here and press control space here we can
see a list of cloud code debug snippets
available for us and because the voting
service is written using node.js we will
go ahead and use the node.js snippet and
here you'll see a number of options but
in most cases you will have to worry
about just three of those so the first
is the name let's name it debug voting
and the second one is the local root
these for the debugger to know the
source code location of your micro
service the source code of the voting
service is in the source folder here so
we'll go ahead and update that and the
third thing is the pod selector these
two uniquely identify the micro service
part in the cluster so we'll go to the
voting dot ml file and see the part
shelter we are using
looks like we are using app colon voting
so let's copy this and use it in the
last row JSON file and because we have
updated the docker file let's do one
more deployment and now the application
has been deployed successfully and now
we have everything we need to debug this
micro service so we'll go to the index
dot J's file and we will set a
breakpoint in the post method here and
we will go to the debug window and press
debug voting button next let's try to
submit the word and the breakpoint has
been hit
now we are live D within the application
deployed in a koban it is cluster so we
can see all the properties of the
request object and the response objects
and we can step through the code line by
line and we also have some debug windows
available on the left hand side so we
have the call stack window and we have a
variables window here where we can watch
the block local and global variables and
we also have the watch window here we
can inspect the variable names
looks like the vote we have just posted
it's coming out fine
let's see what's going on in the words
object here it looks like it's undefined
right now let's step through looks like
we are trying to access a property on
the words object here which is currently
undefined and it's failing with an
internal server error so let's stop
debugging fix this issue will
instantiate with an empty object when
it's undefined and we'll deploy this
let's see if it is for this time and now
we are able to post the word
successfully awesome so let's take a
quick summary of what we have done in
this section so we started with an empty
directory and added the source code for
the micro services along with the docker
files and then we added the kubernetes
manifests that are needed for this
application and then we created our
first deployment profile for our local
environment and and then we diagnosed
the deployment issues with the help of
the logs that were streamed directly to
the output window and finally we were
able to debug an application deployed in
the kubernetes cluster and fix it back
awesome
so next we'll try to take so far we are
only able to see this application on my
machine here next let's try to deploy
this application to a remote cluster so
you all can access it
sir I know is GK would you like to show
us how to create a GK cluster with an ID
yeah I'd love to
it's great how easy it is to create a
cluster right from within the IDE using
cloud code so I'm going to click our
cloud code icon over here and the
activity bar and we're going to see
that's about to populate is all the
clusters we have available in our gke
account and if I want to add a new one
all I have to do is click this plus
button and it's going to open the
cluster creation wizard for me just
gonna let me create a new cluster from
within the IDE and so what I can do is
set a prefault project ID choose a zone
whichever one I'm feeling like today and
customize my cluster so give it a name I
can type and I can do things like enable
sto and cloud run right from in the
cluster creation wizard and then I can
create this cluster right here and I
want to mention that while we're showing
you this awesome workflow and gke we do
know that a lot of you are using
multiple clouds or other clouds so I
want to point out that we have the
support for AWS and Azure as well and so
I can go ahead and click create cluster
and get this up and running we have
limited time for this demo so Sujit and
I already made a cluster that's ready to
go alright not for our voting demo I'm
going to right click here and set it as
the active cluster and then we're gonna
see it populate over here in our cluster
Explorer which we'll talk about in a
little bit we have a few more steps
before the
application is ready to deploy to gke
sujet where do we have to do next next
in order to deploy this application to
the gk cluster you go to the command
palette and use cloud code deploy we
won't be using the default profile
because it is configured to work against
the local environment
we'll use the add edit profile option
here and now we are back to the
deployment profile wizard I'll use the
add new option here to add a new profile
let's call it GK and instead of
inheriting the build settings from the
default profile we'll go ahead and
change it to Google cloud build and now
as you can see the project ID has been
Auto populated with my default Google
Cloud project ID let's continue to
inherit the deployment settings from the
default profile which is currently
configured to use skewed CTL if you need
more customisation options you can
directly work with a scaffold ml file
here I will go ahead and press save and
proceed with the deployment and we will
use the GK profile and we'll use the
cluster that Sarah has just added and
now it's prompting us for the image
history because we are deploying this
application to a remote cluster we also
need to push the images to a registry
which is accessible from that cluster
and it's currently Auto populated with
my default GC adata your registry let's
go ahead and use it
and now the deployment has started when
the department is in progress I would
like to bring to your attention a number
of things that are happening behind the
scenes the cloud code deploy command is
building all the docker files in the
application using Google cloud build
tagging them and pushing them to the
remote registry in this case GC r dot io
and then it will update all the
kubernetes manifests in the application
with a new image path then up then uses
cube CTL to apply the kubernetes
manifest to the remote cluster after
this it will wait till all the
deployment resources are rolled out
successfully it then waits till all the
load balancers and the ingress resources
in the application are assigned an IP
address and finally it will pull all the
publicly exposed endpoints in the
application and display them right here
in the output window
now it's currently waiting for the
English resource let's wait for it for a
few more seconds
awesome so now let's use the link here
and now we are browsing the application
deployed to the GK cluster let's submit
a word and awesome it's working great
I'm glad we got that all working and I
want to take a minute to go back to the
IDE and show you all one of my favorite
features of cloud code which are cluster
Explorer this is really great because it
provides a lot of visibility into your
kubernetes clusters which is something
that I hear from developers which is a
really useful feature of cloud code and
so some things you can do here are see a
lot of your kubernetes resources right
from the IDE and you can perform simple
actions against those and use them to
find out more information about what's
going on so if we want to check out how
our deployments are doing can open
deployments tab and we'll see both our
deployments are running as expected as
indicated by this green icon here if
something wasn't going right that would
be yellow we can look inside of our
deployments to see the replicas and if
we want to scale those will update and
if we want any more information we can
right click to describe our deployment
and so we'll get all that information
here as well we can do some really cool
stings like stream logs from right from
our pods so if we go into our pods and
click on our voting application can
stream logs right here and we'll see
that vote that Sujit just made coming in
down here at the bottom just getting
blocked and if I want to go back to our
application and post another vote we're
going to see that vote coming in here
too as well and then we can go inside of
our containers and get access to our
terminal so if I click on the container
for a voting application and get the
terminal I'm gonna do things like LS
inside see what's inside of our
container right from the cluster
Explorer and then we can check on the IP
addresses for our services right here as
well so we can look at our voting
service and we'll see our IP address and
then we'll see the location of a report
and I want to mention that we have a lot
of really awesome resources available
here too we can see things like secrets
persistent volumes and other environment
variables right from the cluster
Explorer and this is a really great way
to increase the visibility of what's
going on in your cluster and as I
mentioned while we're showing you this
in gke
we do have the cluster Explorer
available for any kubernetes cluster
so let's take a bit of a summary and see
what we've done so far so so far we've
shown you how easy it is to create a
cluster right within the IDE using our
cluster creation wizard it works for AWS
asher and GK we've added a new
deployment deployment profile and then
we've deployed two gke we then showed
you how you can see all of your
kubernetes resources right from the IDE
with our cluster Explorer so let's test
our app and make sure those voting
results are coming in as we would expect
them to there's a little bit awkward
Sujit there are no votes coming in you
write so many bugs in your code yeah my
manager however is an excellent
opportunity to showcase that remote
debug debugging capabilities of the
cloud code extension so let's try to
troubleshoot this issue by debugging the
application directly I guess the GK
cluster and because the docker file that
we have used to deploy the voting
service has the necessary inspect flag
already we don't need to do anything
else we can simply ensure oops
simply ensure that the breakpoint has
been set and we can go to the debug
window and click on the debug watering
button and now we will go back and try
to post a vote yes the breakpoint has
hit and now we are live debugging the
application deployed in the GK a cluster
so similarly we can see all the
properties on the request nor the
response objects and we can step through
line by line
and let's see what's going on with the
whole subject here it looks like the we
expect the words to be stored in this
format but it looks like the words the
keys in the words are stored as indexes
instead of the string so let's see
what's going on with the posted words
here we'll step through and the posted
vote is coming out to be fine and now we
are iterating over the posted votes in
this for loop and we are braiding the
word subject let's go one step further
and see the name it looks like the name
is coming up as a number here let's use
I think this is because we are using for
in loop which iterates over the array
indexes as opposed to the for off loop
which iterates all array values so let's
fix it and press fi I think there is a
small issue here looks like the us it's
continuously streaming the logs I would
like to close and open the application
once again
awesome so so far we have seen how we
can debug a single micro service in the
company's cluster next today I feel a
bit brave and greedy and would like to
show you how we can debug multiple micro
service and application at the same time
maybe I'm pushing our demo cards a bit
too much here but let's try this fingers
crossed for Sujit everyone yeah so
though I haven't explicitly mentioned
the docker file that we are using to
deploy the front end has the necessary
inspect flag enabled so we just have to
create the corresponding debug
configuration for the front end to be
able to debug it so we'll go to the last
edge a Sun and add another snippet let's
rename this to the front end debug front
end and we'll update the local route to
the source code director of the front
end service and we'll update the pod
selector now let's set the breakpoints
so previously I've seen in the results
page or the front end we'll make it call
to the HTTP GET in point of the voting
service so we'll put a breakpoint in the
first method of the front end and we'll
set a breakpoint in the HTTP GET
endpoint of the voting service so next
we'll go to the debug window click on
the debug front end now we will try to
navigate to the results page yes the
breakpoint has hit in the results method
of the front end we can step through and
debug this and next when I press f5 the
breakpoint has sit in the has hit in the
HTTP GET endpoint of the voting service
awesome demo gods are with us so I'll do
one more deployment of the GK cluster so
the code there will be bug free and
Sarah will be happy so this is really
awesome I just want to point out how
easy it was for CJ to bug against the
remote cluster and this is really
helpful because in my conversations with
a lot of developers debugging is one of
the biggest pain points and so we've
just shown you how easy it is to bug
remote cluster and it looks like we're
going to show you a little bit more live
debugging
how you know it's a live demo as Sujit
is diagnosing this problem I just want
to comment on a couple of the ways that
we've shown you how you can troubleshoot
using cloud code we've shown you a lot
of the logging features they're gonna
help you diagnose your issues showing
you that you can debug locally and
against the remote cluster and then
Sujit bravely attempted to debug
multiple micro services which was
successful and so now we're gonna debug
this issue on the spot nobody panic
I'll deploy I'll try to deploy to the GK
cluster once again
all right it's looking good so far
yeah good to keep it very exciting for
you guys but there we go just pretend
like nothing happened let's browse the
application let's post-award and see the
results awesome
it's working great well I'm glad that we
finally got that working thank you for
your support we appreciate it and now
that we have this great audience here I
think we could ask them a question that
would be a little bit more fun should
what do you want to do so I know that
we're working on a lot of awesome new
features for cloud code and I'd love to
get the audience's take on what they'd
like to see in the next release so I
know that we're thinking about things
like how customized CRD and [ __ ] we
should ask the audience what they'd like
to see support for sure let's do this in
order to do this let me introduce
another command called cloud code
continuous deploy previously we have
seen the cloud code deploy command that
does all the grunt work of deploying an
application to a cluster and the cloud
code continuous deploy command takes it
one step further
what does it command does is it
continuously watches the application
directory for any changes and when it
detects any changes it automatically
deploys the application to the cluster
this command will come in particularly
handy when you want to rapidly iterate
on our code so let's see it in action
so I'll go to the command palette and
use cloud code continuous deploy let's
use the default profile so we can
iterate locally and now the first
deployment has started and as soon as
it's complete we can see the status has
changed to watching for changes so I
will go to the index dot HTML file and
update the text here which of these
features we want next awesome so as soon
as I press save the deployment process
has started without having without me
having to explicitly trigger that so
we'll see the URL and we can see that
the text has been updated automatically
for us so now go ahead and change the
options to have
customized CRB and we'll leave the G
Buzzy's I know you say
and now the deployment is again in
progress and refresh and now the options
has have been updated and I'll submit
that and looks like we also have to
update this in the results page so we'll
go back to the results dot HTML page to
the options and we'll paste this and
press save
and once again the the deployment
process has automatically started for us
now we refresh this and now that this
page has been updated as well so in
order to stop the continuous deployment
we just have to click on the watching
for changes and click on stop continuous
deployment so now I will do one last
deployment to the GK cluster so this
application will be available for all of
us with the new questionnaire so also
the cloud code continuous deploy command
is smart enough to only deploy those
micro services that are being changed by
the user so in this case only the
front-end service was getting redeployed
again and again one more thing I would
like to bring your attention here is
that as they deployed this application
back and forth between the local and the
GK enrollments I really didn't have to
think about whether my using the right
build settings of the right deploy
settings or even the cluster that I'm
actually deploying my application to we
just shot create a deployment profile
for each of these environments and the
cloud code is taking care of the rest
so we'll browse this application one
last time see if everything is working
as we would want awesome now let's go
back to the slides and take a quick
summary of what we have done in this
section so in this section we are able
to remote debug the application deployed
in the GK cluster and fix a bug and then
with the help of the demo guards we are
able to debug multiple micro services at
the same time and finally we are able to
use a cloud code continuous deploy
command
rapidly iterate on our code and update
the questionnaire great so now that
we've got our voting application up and
running we'd love to hear your votes so
you can go to this link right here at
cloud code slash demo or you can scan
the QR code on the screen and for those
of you you might notice that this domain
doesn't look exactly like the IP address
that sujet was testing against I want to
tell you that we did connect our gke
cluster to this domain before the demo
so I promise you it's the same code and
we'd really like to see your votes cuz
we're gonna be checking these later and
so if you don't vote we're just gonna
get what Sujit wants in cloud could and
so while you're all voting I just want
to take a little bit of time to
summarize some great cloud code features
that we've talked about today so as you
saw we have support for local
development with mini cube and docker
desktop as I mentioned we have support
for any kubernetes cluster with our
cluster Explorer and then cluster
creation with AWS Asher and gke we also
support multiple environments containers
and languages this is a lot of
flexibility with this tooling and this
is just the beginning for cloud code and
so we're really looking forward to
continuing to expand our support to meet
your needs and now the moment you've all
been waiting for how can you get your
hands on cloud code today so you can
install and find all the documentation
you need for cloud code at cloud
google.com slash code or you can scan
this QR code here on the screen and
cloud code is also available in the
visual studio code marketplace for those
of you who use IntelliJ I also want to
take this time to mention that we do
have cloud code for IntelliJ which you
can find in the JetBrains plug-in
repository and you can find all the
documentation at the same link on the
screen and so we're really excited for
you to start using cloud code and as I
mention in the beginning we really do
care about your feedback and we take it
into consideration when we're making
these products so we're it shoot we're
flat we're logging all of our issues on
github so you can file issues there and
our team be very fast to respond to you
and take those issues into consideration
when we're updating cloud code so we do
encourage you to do that and while
you're all at the conference I'd like to
encourage you to come talk to other user
experience researchers at our CPU X
booth there's a lot of us there and
we're always looking to talk to you
about your needs and pain points so we
can improve our products so please come
by and talk to me and other researchers
at the ux booth and if you'd like other
ways to participate in our research and
inform our products sign up at user
research Google com
so let's check those votes Wow all right
how is winning that's awesome that's
really cool to see interest for a lot of
these different features and Sujit and I
will bring that back to our team to make
sure that your voices are heard and we
can make those changes for cloud code to
meet your needs I think we're just
scratching the surface of helping our
developers and operators to be more
productive and we really hope you all
will be will join us in this journey
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]